I was gone Bros minutes I hate you grats
you ruined my life grats why did you
have to sleep with the cows I thought we
had the bank we gotta play three games
let's start off with my favorite I
haven't played it yet but it's my
favorite don't worry about it don't you
worry don't you worry child son I'm
sorry I have a condition
all right get ready all right first game
it's called MLG flappy bird 4:20 Snoop
is there MLG is there fedoras there all
the memes are here let's meme it up
rest in peace Peroni don't even Shawn Oh
I decided that's pretty [ __ ] good let
me nada got me 360 hardscope haha oh god
damn sure damn it always had a newsman
Jesus Christ finis Allah I lose my 420
powers Oh
song name it's the route sensor ah I
want to see killcam with that one
sanic Oh gets in it yes you're so fast
gotta go fass sure what I went to space
oh no poor flappy try to go to space I
actually enjoyed this game it's [ __ ]
amazing let's see if we can get in you
my ears are bleeding
this is great Diane Shawn doctor told me
never play more MLG games look what I'm
doing the things I do you put your brush
how far is gonna go this is ridiculous
I'm sure what I'd am a mlady someone got
600 a yep
don't look at me like that what watch
attack okay all right uninstall I have
to uninstall the game I'm sorry oh boy
yes who comes up with these ideas
they're so good oh my god i hink chose
classic they even have a dubstep mode
whoa creativity gets up all right let's
start with classic what is what what is
this you [ __ ] call this grass
simulator that's the worst grass I've
seen in my life
are you [ __ ] kidding me what you
doing oh you wouldn't stop twitching you
goddamn cow all right so we have some
demon cows in a grass simulator game
great just what I had hope stop oh god
this is terrifying all right you know
what I'm going in I'm going in
no more grass for me oh god the grass is
everywhere oh it's everywhere
make the gret a gun really like hey go
shoot the grass or take this scratch
you'll never get Bella infinite demo
slo-mo shooting that grass 360 360
noscopes all right the grass is still
alive I don't know what to do do I shoot
the cows
I'm sorry demon cow you fatty out can't
kill them can kill the devil huh
this game is on Steam you can buy this
game now don't see why anyone wouldn't
buy this game such a [ __ ] good game I
paid money for this what the game
doesn't like insults sorry didn't know
you can hear me game what what is that
what the [ __ ] is that
a mite I think I'm getting exorcised no
wait Exorcist [ __ ] I don't know that
would shut up-a ass what is that what is
that what the [ __ ] too much grass or hay
maybe I'm judging the game too harshly
what about job set mode I'm sure it's
great doesn't [ __ ] work
there's a grass mug there's a [ __ ]
grass mowed in grass simulator and it's
just growing grass that's it can't can't
go back can i I'm stuck in the grass
mowed forever all right keep looking at
the guys hump
looks like we I gotta have to restart
the game paid money for this
I have range mode as well you press Q to
cycle weapons
I could've [ __ ] told me that before
I'm not even shooting right I hate you
grads you ruined my life grats why did
you have to sleep with the cows I
thought we had some Fang comes a point
in every man's life where you just have
to realize that you've gone too far
this game is a joke and not a very funny
one
I want my $2.00 back please send me your
money so I can get the back so I can
stop crying
don't you see my tears they're almost as
realized this game is a good game all
right we're playing Brown atcha
yeah we're in Brattle net sorry brothel
Nara it's not very Bridal not sure this
game is no brothel nature at all to be
honest it runs first I hear something
boy bridge I brought quiet I think I
hear something might be my uncle Oh what
you are receiving it might be fake for
now as long as you I'm not safe for now
what the [ __ ] are you talking about by
pressing on what do I know
oh I'm not safe don't wake the missus oh
god don't happen very bisa my cancer
weapon Macca pressing are and fire play
what best game ever you have an 8 mm mm
you have died
respawn thank you all right now we can
face the burden not sure I look up in
the sky
there's a boy flying boy the [ __ ] that's
either my uncle Jerry fapping to the
left or it's all God now it is alright
we killed it now we shall minecraft
build on it yes alright
let's kill some more oh there's another
one it's coming right for me
boom smack ohh smack ohh Matt Sean it
came right for me it's not my [ __ ]
fault alright let's hit some sweet MLG
360 noscope
oh god that that's it what the [ __ ] is
that I don't know what you are but I
need to die alright let's go to the
mansions and do some no scripts he's
trying to kill cat meows i ec that one
I'm gonna noscope him I don't know how
gotcha almost what is this let's aim for
the higher mountain what the [ __ ] is
that the beer thinks he has claimed a
mountain well we're just gonna have to
see you bet we're just yeah man I hear
someone and double-click a food item to
eat it Shh don't tell me what to do game
I'm climbing this mountain it's the last
thing I'll ever do yes oh oh I'm fine
I'm fine I'm fine
hey beer what you got to do about it huh
oh god oh god oh god don't penny yeah
panic panic panic panic panic oh yeah
yeah oh [ __ ] I don't know what's
happening
let's skin him a lab whoa this music man
I love it hey dirty beast I'm the king
of the nature oh god damn it
oh [ __ ] make you think oh god oh god oh
god oh god okay okay uh help it's dark
I'm scared damn it alright friends last
day for today last day for today it's
called welcome to oculus people are
saying it's pretty damn amazing so I'm
excited to try what the [ __ ] was that
let's go baby but reopen can you feel
the price then you feel it
just captivated our imagination for
years yep this is it tribe for me to
learn stuff I got it's a trap
Oh May freakin get that stone hella
stones something about the buzzer
country of visiting other worlds has
always enticed us again don't forget of
lurkers its yet the advent of the
campaign not a key element in the long
journey ah the memories but we knew
something was still missing
I'm ready really of oculus what is
happening bro what are you do what is
this as you take a look around the room
you physician I live in a damnable sense
of space yeah you're right
for instance as this pipe where you
still have the urge to duck out of the
way out now I mean yeah no I'm not and
as this block lowers overhead you feel a
sense of uneasiness oh god I mean not a
big deal okay fine you win what do you I
do the room it feels almost like you
could reach out and touch it you don't
know me okay you're right but you don't
know me alright even when placed into an
empty room I bet you will still get that
falling sensation in the pit of your
stomach Nick you don't know that that's
a hold on your God
hahaha damnit how does he know
everything
slit if that's Leonard this is a slender
Matalin book sensations the traditional
video games or movies just never could
don't
Slenderman I'm watching you dammit I
don't like this is this is his trap
isn't it
what happened what happened oh god I
knew it I [ __ ] it I am naked what I
screwed up I thank you play what are you
doing in my video all right that was
welcome to our beautiful us that was
[ __ ] beautiful bravo Bravo
I don't know what is your opinion about
VR breasts let me know in the comments
and in that I want to thank you for
watching this video I had a lot of fun
playing with you before us today thank
you for leaving like and as always stay
awesome guys